Sao ngay ngay ngay mừng tán tháng tương năm 2018, một vụ tên án sử dã tại Sao hàng thuật,
lần đầu khiến bác người từ vòng.
Tông tin bà đầu, thời điểm trên, chức xe tại trở bú nhìn biên của một công ty vẫn thông đang
thì công công chính các quang trên định lối tà dôn.
Sau khi hành thình công việc trong móc dịch chuyển xuống lối, chức xe bất ngờ mất thắng,
bà vào vách văn phòng của một công ty dồi mối dừng lại.
Hậu qua, bác người từ vòng, quông, nở cắt tê, sinh năm 2018,
lời về mở, sinh năm 2018, cùng chú Sao hàng thuật.
Nội tê nữa, sinh năm 2018, còn tâm như một chú Sao.
Cần thơ và một người bị thuật là nội tê tê, sinh năm 2018,
chú Sao hàng sân, ngay an đang được cấp dữ tại mình với đa khóa mình thuật.
Hến vụ việc đang được điều tra là mỏ.